it's it's great to be back a corn Li
every time I come here which is not as
often as I'd like I always wish I came
more often because there's so many great
people here and so many friends I will
try and come more often but I think it's
been about 10 years since I was last
here yeah so I'm going to talk about
development which is what we study very
similar to the work you know from from
Mike's lab and you know I'm really
fascinated by this idea that genes
control development it's a very simple
idea but you know development is
obviously very complex the generation of
form of three-dimensional structures but
the idea that we can tease is afar by
finding individual genes that controlled
specific aspects of development is
something that that I find very
attractive because I want to know how
things work ever since I was a kid I
would be taking toys apart and breaking
them you know and finding out how do you
know how machines work so I want to know
how plants work and specifically how the
how the morphology is generated and you
know potentially we could use that to
improve crops I don't know maybe I'm
very naive but you know I think you know
we we should always think about a
potential applications for work
so what very much like Mike's lab we
study the meristems the shrewdest
meristems and I always I always sort of
assumed that everybody knows what a
meristem is that I know most people
don't but anyway the meristem in maize
which is when I'll talk about today is
found right at the base of the seedling
not up here which is where most people
guess it will be also people think it's
here but it's actually right at the base
but if you're very patient and dissect
away all the leaf primordia down here
then you're rewarded by this amazing
structure that the shoot meristem which
I I think is beautiful and it's this
dome of cells themselves that throughout
the life of the plant generate all the
organs that are required for it fruit
for growth and development so that's a
scanning eeehm because the meristem is
pretty tiny spider a tenth of a
millimeter in diameter but this
structure obviously is critical for fun
development because it makes all the
structures of the shoot including the
leaves the axillary meristems which make
the inflorescences the ears and also the
tassel so
critical structure and it's something we
can analyze and understand using
genetics actually 25 years ago when Mike
and I are in Berkeley I remember Ian's
Sussex told me that the meristem was a
black box it was a killer project but a
postdoc on that because you couldn't you
couldn't understand it it was so it's so
mysterious but you know he didn't
although he wrote the book on meristem
Steve's on Sussex he didn't use a lot of
genetics in his lab I think he came
before the era of genetics so genetics
is the key really to understanding this
ok so what you should also realize is
the meristem does not also make leaves
but it of course after transition to
flowering it produces the reproductive
organs reproductive structures and so
these are also shooting meristems and so
you have the axillary shoot marathons
makes the ear primordia to make the ears
and the apical shoot meristem produces
the terminal tassel that is similar it's
similar in structure to the ears except
it has branches of course the tassel is
branched in maize but these are all Mary
senses are all meristem structures and
we can study genes that affect you know
all of these different stages of
development but we tend to focus on the
ear just because that's where the
phenotypes that we work on them or
dramatic so we look a lot of ear
primordia and these things that we
affectionately call baby ears right so
that as sometimes guess is in trouble
with FedEx when we shoot packages
labeled baby ears strange reactions but
anyway yeah yeah so you're all familiar
with the ear of corn of course you've
eaten this and everybody loves it I hope
but we look at the ears when they're
about this stage this is 2 millimeters
by the thickness of a quarter and at
this stage already
most of the morphogenesis the initiation
of all the structures has occurred and
on the flanks of the apical meristem you
have all these primordia forming these
are called spikelet pairs and they form
spikelets and then florets and this is
what produces the seeds so the meristem
at this very early stage is already
making this very regular rows of
primordia that will make the rig
the morphology is set up very early so
there it is again and these are all
scanning Ian's by the way and they look
impressive but these are really easy to
take so there's this just live tissue we
put it in this SEM and two minutes later
we have anything which like this you
should play around with that so we've
characterized a lot of the genes that
are involved in your development and
I'll just give you an outline as some of
them I mean there are a lot of different
things going on here so they'd be in the
inflorescence
there are leaves that are produced but
they're actually suppressed their growth
is suppressed to promote growth of the
meristems and that's a class of genes
called tassel sheath which when Whipple
is now focusing on he's calling the
first one of those in my lab but yet has
his own group now working those the
axillary meristems are initiated and
that's a lot of the genes involved in
that process of Austin sequence as we
know also from Arabidopsis and work from
Impala Max Dean and Andrea gala body has
weight one on these genes
we've worked we work and continue to
work on genes that impose determinacy so
this is really a branching series of
branching events actually three rounds
of branching producer florets
but then that indeterminacy has to be
turned off so determinacy has to be fair
it has to be imposed and that is
characterized by a class of genes called
the remote genes and we're working those
two but for today's seminar because I
know it's lunchtime
everybody's gonna get hungry I'm gonna
focus just on one group of genes and
those are the one that's involved in
maintaining the stem cells right at the
tip and these are the very famous genes
known from our our daughters from the
work of Elliot Meyerowitz many other
groups the Callado genes and the whistle
genes so that's what I will focus on
today now we've known for a really long
time actually since 1920s and before
that the meristem has some kind of
program for controlling its size so this
is you know the meristem is a structure
of proliferating cells but the cells are
not proliferating out of control of
course it's very carefully controlled
and Mary Pilkington did these very nice
experiments in in the
1920s where she would remove over leaf
primordia from meristems I think this is
in in B and then bisect the meristem
with a razor blade and then each half
will regrow regenerate and produce new
meristems that are the same size as the
original meristem also so that the
meristem has some kind of internal
program to control its size and we know
now from a lot of work mostly in
Arabidopsis actually almost exclusive in
Arabidopsis that this this mechanism for
controlling size is through this
classical cavada willed feedback pathway
and work on that has told us that there
are two really important groups of stem
cells in the meristem right at the tip
you have the true initials the stem
cells that we know from clonal analysis
these these are the true progenitor
cells of the shoot and then below that
there's a group of cells in purple here
which is called the organizing center
and basically to understand how the
meristem is is maintained you have to
understand that there's a a crosstalk or
a feedback between these two groups of
cells so the the the organizing Center
sends a positive signal to the stem
cells to tell it to divide okay so that
you need to promote stem cell
differentiation let's maintain the shoot
but to maintain this as an ordered
structure this has to be kept in balance
and it's kept in balance by a negative
signal central as themselves back to the
organizing Center okay so so
mechanistically that's how it how it
works
and what are the genes involved well in
the stem cells you have the Claddagh
genes as I mentioned and up to now most
of the work has been done by a couple of
news feed receptors called clavata one
and Claddagh two and their ligand which
is a small secreted peptide encoded by a
gene called cavada 3 so this this gene
makes a pre peptide of about 100 amino
acids there's cleaved in 12 amino acids
signal is secreted and it binds to
cavada 1 and activate signaling from
this kinase and then that organizing
Center is characterized by this famous
homie domain transcription factor were
show which is expressed
down here in those cells so we shall
promote stem cell fade clavata genes
repress stem cell fate okay and we know
this is important because in nature in
in the in the wild and in our Gardens we
see plants where we've lost this
negative feedback and I call this stem
cells under control the botanical term
for that is face iation and in that case
the stem cells over proliferate and you
get these amazing convoluted shoots or
inflorescences or or flowers or fruits
okay so tomato for example work from
this equipment and a nest abundant
efficient at a closeout of you is what
gives rise to this beefsteak tomato okay
so had to show this being a cornell but
also this is a very famous picture from
Ithaca 1929 actually I just realized it
this is the same year that I've nursed
him by section experiment was done so
1929 was it a good year for for plant
biology but anyway this is Barbara
McClintock who discovered transposons
and later of course went to Cold Spring
Harbor what why do we study this in
maize because as I said most of the
foundational work has been done in
Arabidopsis or a blob this is a fast
cycling planet this small genome maze is
a slow cyclic plant with a huge genome
but still I think we can find new things
in maize and one of the one of the great
things about maize is we have a huge
mutant collection right that is
generated in part by the scientists who
developed these transposon lines and so
in maize we have a lot of Levada type
mutants which is the foundation of the
word for that I'm going to tell you
about so we call we don't leave we don't
call these cavada we call them face dat
ear so face hated again is the botanical
term for these massively expanded
stemless and these mutants and this is
just five I'm showing we have another 20
that we haven't characterized yet but I
thought I would keep it focused some of
these mutants is you would expect we
clone them and they're awful lots of the
Clamato genes right this is not
surprising so td1 is cavada one is lr
receptor PHA two is cavada two
and then others that we've cloned have
been different so we have found new
things in maize that were not discovered
in Arabidopsis so they three is a new
type of lrl receptor that is functions
in some how in the Claddagh feedback but
was not characterized in a rubber topsis
but it does function in Arabidopsis
faith four is a transcription factor and
I'll talk a little bit about ct2 that's
a G protein that we think is involved in
signaling downstream of these receptors
okay so we have a large collection
mutants and it's really really great
material to work with to discover the
genes to control this meristem feedback
now another thing I'll talk about today
and this is more recent work is the idea
that we these genes may be useful for
controlling yield rates so in maize
there's some you know breeders measure
yield traits such as you know obviously
total massive corn that's harvested but
they also use more quantitative traits
such as this one kernel row number which
is a number of kernel rows around the
circumference of the ear so if you break
the ear in half you you can just
currently so this one has 12 rows it's
wrong if you count quickly it has 22 and
we have this idea that by controlling
size of the meristem you could control
the number of of rows because you see
this is this is now looking down from
the top of the ear ear primordium and
this is the mat the apical meristem and
then all these primordia are the ones
that are making the rows of seeds so you
know naively you could save well if we
can make this meristem bigger then we
could make more rows of seeds right so
that's what we want to do so the other
thing that's really interesting about
kernel row number of course is that
maize itself is a manmade crop it's
genetically modified by humans over the
past 10,000 years and it's derived as
you know work from john doe billion at
Butler and others has shown that maize
is derived from teosinte which had only
a single row of seeds and human
selection over the course of thousands
of years gave rise to the amazing ear of
corn that we have today we know this is
genetic right so
number is acute acts as a cutie else
it's heritable and you can map loose
either control it and we also know this
was a gradual process so primitive carbs
of maize found in high altitude caves in
Mexico you know look like this or this
they may have a dros or twelve rows and
of course more modern varieties that we
eat or cows eat have 1820 alright so it
said it was a trade that was gradually
selected over the course of the last ten
thousand years okay so our mutants may
have something to do with this that's
what we want to find out but you know
our face Yeti mutants have a lot more
rows but you see the rows are really
disorganized and the yield of these
mutants is very low like a farmer would
never want to grow this but you know
they're basically they make too many
primordia so it's almost like a cancer
the meristems are proliferating
proliferating and in the end it's making
hundreds of primordial here but none of
them are productive they just abort
because there's too many of them
and they're fighting for resources right
so we want to try and control that so
the model are sort of thinking is like
this so if we if we knock out one of
these faced headed genes completely so
zero activity we have a massive of
obliteration hi Colonel rose but very
low yield but if we could make an allele
of a gene like this that had reduce
activity like a hyper morphic allele
maybe we could make the meristem a
little bit bigger but it's still
organized and make more rows of seeds
around this bigger meristem and somehow
optimize yield at least Colonel row
number so that's what we'll get to it
towards the end okay so we call this
like the Goldilocks principle or the
sweet spot right - too hard or too cold
is not good that you want to be right in
the middle and at the right right
temperature or right level of gene
expression okay so I want to go through
one example of a mutant we've cloned
just to give it yeah just give you an
dear that the process we go through in
finding the genes and characterizing
these mutations so this is one in the
one mutant and this this mutant is
called compact one two so this gets
confusing it this should be called fated
ear or something but this mutant was
discovered in 1960s before I was born so
I didn't get to name this and I'm I
respect old matron ethicists so I don't
want to change the name so I keep this
name Kampf I plan to and as its name
suggests the mutants are very compact
they're dwarfs but I don't care about
that so much what I care about is they
have faded years this is I'm really
interested in okay so we cloned this
gene and it was probably three years of
work but like most people I just show it
in a single slide and we found that
encodes a protein called G alpha or it
which is the alpha subunit of a trimeric
g protein so these these jeans are super
famous in mammalian systems because
they're that they G alpha is a signaling
protein as gtp a's that interacts with a
class of receptors that are called not
surprisingly GPCRs results with
g-protein coupled receptors and GPCRs in
yeast and in humans are these seven pass
transmembrane proteins and these are
targets for about a half of all
pharmaceutical drugs that have developed
first for humans so so that's you know
very very important pharmaceutical
industry so so G alpha is the signaling
protein that when these receptors are
activated this protein is a gtp a is it
will be activated by transferring gdp to
GTP becomes activated dissociates from
its subunits later in gamma and those
dissociated subunits go away and start
signaling cascades so because these
proteins were so famous in mammalian
systems people started working on them
in Arabidopsis and made mutants in them
and found that they did all sorts of
different things so basically anybody
who screen them for phenotype would find
their favorite phenotypes of if you were
looking on cell proliferation on home
different hormones or sugar signaling or
defense responses people found a lot of
phenotypes but there was nothing
specifically up to now to do with
meristems or development so we thought
we had a unique angle here because we'd
shown that this mutant in G alpha had a
very clear meristem size phenotype okay
so then what we do or what we do all
along with these mutants is we try to
put the genes into pathways and we do
that by epistasis analysis and so we
make double mutants and here we made it
a double mutant between CT to us through
our G alpha mutant and Fae to which if
you remember is one of the Clamato
receptors one of these feedback stem
cell receptors and we found that the
double mutants and here we're measuring
we did this by measuring meristem size
but we can also do it in a more easy way
by Counting spinal density in the
tassels we found that double mutants
look like the single mutants in terms of
cycle density and so this is what we
would call egg stasis and suggest
they're in a pathway now we did a
something that serves as a control
experiment a double mutant with TD 1
which is amazed the different maze about
a receptor maze cavada one here we see
an additive phenotype and this suggests
that seats two and td1 are in different
pathways and in parallel okay
so we had epistasis with Fay two
suggesting these proteins may be acting
together so we wanted to look further at
that and so we made a GFP or yfp fusion
of CT 2 and infused it in frame with the
native promoter with the CT 2 coding
region we could image it and it's on the
membrane which is what is predicted from
all the work in in in mammals and
fortunately as we hoped and expected we
saw high expression in meristem so it is
expressed in the meristem and has some
interesting patterns I don't really have
time to go through that
but you know so these you know reporters
as Mike said can be very useful for just
looking at where things are expressed
but they're also really useful for more
functional assays and so we had a
hypothesis that CT 2 might interact with
this Clamato receptor and using the GFP
is a tag we could use that for IP
experiments you know precipitation and
so we pull down CT 2 with with a GFP
antibody in an immuno precipitation
experiment and we actually had a we
already had an antibody to detect fate
to that shown here the specific antibody
that detects his fatal receptor in the
membrane fraction and we showed that if
we IP CT 2 we pull down PHA to receptor
so pulling down the g-protein also pulls
down the receptor and we did controls
within a different membrane protein
because these membrane IPs are actually
very tricky and you can get a lot of
background but we did a different memory
protein pin one when we agreed that one
we don't pull down the receptor so we
think it's specific
so our model now is that this g-protein
is signaling from the Claddagh receptor
from play to right so if that's true we
should be able to see some other kind of
Clamato phenotypes you know a mutant
well we saw it has big meristems but you
can get big meristems for a lot of
different reasons
so to see if it's really in the club on
a pathway does it really need si again
first developed in Arabidopsis where you
can actually synthesize about a three
head type
so remember Claddagh 3 is the ligand for
these receptors it's a 12 we know as a
peptide so you can just you know ask gen
script to make it and a week later you
have the peptide if you add that to
plans it will inhibit meristem
operations right so mutants in these
genes the meristem is over cliff rate if
you are add back the peptide in excess
you get the negative phenotype which is
the opposite phenotype which is you
suppress meristem growth so basically we
do this experiments with embryos because
in maize embryos they're big enough that
we can detect dissect them and culture
them and the meristem is expo
so we can easily access them with a
peptide
so we culture the member after embryos
on media with colada 3 or a control with
a scrambled peptide so it's the same
sequence but just that the order of the
amino acids is scrambled so it shouldn't
have any effect and when we do that we
find that with a scramble of peptide we
don't see any difference between the
mutant and the wild-type but when we
treat these with cavada 3 the wild-type
meristems their growth is inhibited as
we predicted the G alpha mutants CT 2
they're also inhibited but much less
than the wild-type so we say they're
partially insensitive to to this peptide
and to us this says that CT 2 is somehow
involved in transmitting this signal
from the peptide to the meristem
proliferation pathway ok so to summarize
this part what we think is happening now
is that you know in in animals and in
yeast this hedge trimeric g protein
complex interacts with these 7 pass
receptors is GPCRs but implanted seems
to be very different as there are GPCRs
implants or at least proteins predicted
to be GPCRs but they haven't been
convinced link shown to interact with G
alpha but we found that G alpha
interacts with a Clamato receptor they -
and so we published that a few years ago
and I I was kind of nervous about
publishing something that's so
dramatically different between animals
and plants but since then they've been
several other papers showing that indeed
G proteins do interact with lrr
receptors in plants so this is both in
development and also in defense signal
so now we wanted to look at you know is
this just an effect of G alpha or is
this whole heterotrimeric complex
involved so as I said it's a three
protein complexes G alpha G beta and G
gamma and we actually went after G G
beta next for the obvious example a
reason that it's a single copy gene so
mutants should have a phenotype
so and the other reason was that work in
Arabidopsis published very soon after
our work in mais actually showed that in
Arabidopsis G beta controls meristem
size so we had G alpha controlling
meristem size in our mutants in an
Arabidopsis is G beta right so it's a G
beta mutants in Arabidopsis have big
meristems and this group in Japan found
that G beta interacts with our PK 2
which is not not a classic Levada
receptor but is a Colorado related
receptor that also functions in the
meristem so it seems this precedent that
these G proteins probably the whole
complex is functioning in meristem ik
controls ok so this was our first CRISPR
experiment we did this with Nene at Iowa
State and we were super excited this
about three years ago we thought we
going to get these plants back and
they'll have big meristems and we got
them and we were very disappointed that
they were dead right so this for
development biologists this is not a
very satisfying in type so basically
well we could recover these because we
got events like they were heterozygous
but when we solved them the home ago
homozygous G beta mutants they
germinated and then within three days
they just dead right this is in stark
contrast to Herbert OPS's remember I
told you you're obnoxious mutants have
big marathons but you know the plants
themselves look pretty normal so we were
really surprised so we looked a little
bit more closely at this and what we
realized is that the plants were not
dying we're not just arresting but they
were actually becoming very necrotic and
we saw that cells were dying the tissue
was turning brown very quickly and so we
stayed we did some assays for hydrogen
peroxide and for elite cell viability
and we quickly realize that yeah these
mutants were actually undergoing some
kind of autoimmune response by they're
actually killing themselves we also had
looked at pathogenesis related gene
expression so we think this is some kind
of autoimmune response and it kind of
well it makes sense based on what else
I'll tell you next but yeah with some
we also grew we grew their ceilings or
seeds under sterile conditions and they
still die so it's not a pathogen thing
it's there they're just killing
themselves okay so this sort of makes
sense based on worth in Arabidopsis
groups have looked at the g-protein
mutants in a red abscess and G beta
mutants actually are more susceptible to
various pathogens so this is a mock
inoculation of wild-type Columbia and
then the AG b1 the arrival of Co beta
mutants are much more susceptible to
arrange different diseases so it seems
that as I alluded to earlier these G
proteins are probably involved in
signaling from defense receptors as well
as from the Claddagh development
receptors and in fact a really nice
story came out last year from jamming
Joe's group actually showed that G beta
interacts with FL s 2 so FL s 2 is an
immune receptor in Rabbid Oxus that's
involved in the innate immune signaling
and G beta interacts with F s 2 and that
explains the phenotypes and it actually
seems to function as a positive
regulator of immunity but through its
interaction with life flies through but
also by stabilizing a dime string kinase
of F flies to called big one so G beta
functions in immunity in Arabidopsis and
the mutants are more susceptible to
diseases but this really doesn't still
doesn't understand explain why our maze
mutants are much more severe right
amazements are not more susceptible
they're just dead even in the object so
we we figure this out by thinking about
how you know how again how immunity
signaling works in plants so you
probably or much more familiar with this
than I am but as you know plants are
constantly bombarded by pathogens and
pathogens secrete effectors into the
plant cell that tried to suppress that
the cellular immune signaling pathways
or
defense pathways and in the case of a
viable infection where there's no
resistance then
the plant is susceptible and will be
affected by the pathogen now plants have
evolved these are proteins resistance
proteins that can either interact
directly with the with the bacterial
effectors a pathogen factor but more
frequently is thought that these are
proteins interact with another host
protein another con protein that is
targeted by the effector and they're
actually guarding on surveying that host
protein to see if it's under attack by a
pathogen effector
right so this is called the god
hypothesis and these cellular these
plant proteins that are by the are
proteins are called guardians they're
being guarded so that when the plant is
under attack
I have been an effector it it knows it
right and it's known that if you if you
mutate these guard ease then the plant
again thinks is being attacked and you
get an autoimmune phenotype so that's
what we think is happening with G beta
that we think G beta is guarded by an
our protein or an R gene and when we
mutated the punt think it's is being
attacked by pathogens and it kills eggs
every cell now we can test that one way
accessor is that our genes are very
polymorphic between different eco types
and so we took our G beta mutant as a as
a head obviously we can't cross the
homozygotes but we cross the head to all
of the NAM maize diversity lines and
made f2s and we found that for most of
them we still got the same phenotype
that the mutants were lethal but we have
a few lines where now the phenotype is
suppressed and we get plants back
they're not completely wild-type but
they're not dead obviously they grow
they're making fluorescence is so we
think these suppressors are lines
types that no longer contain the our
gene and in fact we've we've mapped one
of these and it Maps in a region we
don't know the exact geniu but it maps
in the region where there is a predicted
RG so this was a bit of an aside for us
but it could actually get us through a
new arginine maize which will be cool
actually very few our genes have been
cloned in maize up to now okay but
anyway we were excited to have these
and because now we say this is now the
developmental phenotype of Chi beta and
it actually looks very similar to G
alpha that CT 2 phenotype
now we've suppressed the defense
responses and they have so we call these
G beta suppressed they have big
meristems and we think this is
significant and actually coming back to
the concept I I brought up earlier G
beta in maize in G wasps analysis
associates with Colonel Rohl number the
trade that I I mentioned that we think
is associative marathon site so so we're
still working on this but we think at
least up to now we've think that G beta
is also functioning in them in meristem
signaling okay so now we have a
situation where Fei to this club our doe
receptor is probably signaling through G
alpha and G beta this probably G gamma
also but we haven't done that yet
now there's work in Arabidopsis that the
awful log of FEI to which is cavada two
signals through a different protein and
that protein is called korean a korean a
is a kind well it was when it was first
clone it was published to be a kinase
that it's actually a pseudo pilot's so
it's a protein that has homology to
Karnazes but has no kinase activity
probably acting as some kind of scaffold
so you know i'm always interested in
this question about how meristem has
evolved and whether the same pathways at
present in maize or I say monocots and
dicots or whether they evolve or evolve
separately or evolve to be different
right so we have here we have one
receptor Fei to and it's all gonna
Robert offices right so presumably doing
the same thing they have the same
phenotype but that up to now the
genetics suggests that this one goes
through G proteins and this one goes
through Carinae so we really wanted to
know is this a trans pcs difference or
is our both systems operating in both
monocots and dicots right so we were
fortunate to get a mutant of coronae in
maize we got this from bob Miglia
pioneer from their transposon
collection and we also got another
allele from the amazing populations
developed by Jerry new for the EMS
populations and we found that coronae
indeed also is face eiated so big
meristems and their face iation in the
ear so seems that both korean a and g
are functioning maize in in meristem
signal now again we use double mutants
and so we have I should have had a
summary here but we have Fae to the
receptor and then two possible
downstream signaling components G alpha
and Corrine a if we make double mutants
between G alpha and Corrine a third
they're additive or synergistic so we
get these crazy face iation it's much
more severe than the single mutants so
this suggests their different pathways
okay now however what's a bit of a lag
yeah when we make double mutants between
the receptor and coronae so between FA 2
and current a here we see epistasis so
the double mutants look like the single
mutants rights that's in Maitreya
meristems or just looking at them they
kind of look not that much different so
so PHA - and Karina are in the same
pathway renee and CT tour and different
pathways and our earlier published work
has shown that fate U and C teetering
different pathways so this is gonna be
on the test I know it's getting very
complicated but I'll have a summary ok
so what we think is the receptor has two
different outputs Karen a and G alpha it
turns out and this is from some early
work that we publish that I'm not going
to talk much about that there are two
different Claddagh three related
proteins in maze that affect meristems
one of them is called CLE 7 which we
think is the carotid 3 over log the
other one is called FC P 1 and we Chris
perd both of these to get phenotypes and
we have
vacation in both cases but what we find
and this is the important result is that
again we do these peptide sensitivity
assays where if a gene is involved in
possession of a peptide the mutant
should be insensitive right and we found
that G alpha or CT 2 is sensitive to one
of the two peptides but not the other
and Carinae is sensitive to the other
peptide and not the first one so yeah so
basically this is our model I know it's
a lot of data and it's even I get
confused by this but our model is that
we have two different signals going
through the same receptor different
peptides one is Cle 7 which is the maze
version of Callado 3 and one is FC p1
which is different about a three related
peptide two different signals go through
the same receptor and they come out of
different outputs now you can ask me
later how this works and it's it's not
that confusing because we think that
these receptors do not work by
themselves when they work in complexes
so we think that they - probably is a
scaffold for other receptors which give
the specificity so maybe one receptor
complex binds Claddagh 3 and another
receptor complex I am sexy p1 and we'd
really like to know what those are but
we're not there yet but at least
phenomenologically I think this is
interesting because it shows how you can
get different signal inputs and outputs
going through its common receptor so I
think it's quite interesting I'm
actually going to skip that anyway ok so
there's another area we are very
interested in which is looking at
natural variation and some of this is
actually what inspired by work from Ed
buckler and Mike Lee and others where
they've shown that we can map qtls for a
kernel row number which is the trait we
eventually want to get to so there is
natural genetic variation in maize for
we think for meristem size certainly
fir'd for seed seed number and the
is me in our summer field last year this
is actually a real calm plant I didn't
glue these together not I'm the scale by
answer it's huge this is a land Mexican
land race from simit that the maize and
wheat Research Centre in Mexico and I
ordered these seeds or seeds of this
line because they're annotated as being
faced here I see I did and they are and
this is really amazing this is a land
race that people grow and eat in Mexico
and it's it's amazing and I had my I
asked my undergrads to shoot back these
plants and they were like Jaime on the
inch of their shoulders and bringing
ladders and then I told me you can just
bend them over because they have dogs
like about six inches thick so they're
really strong but it was fun okay
so we are trying to map this but we're
not there yet we're close but another
approach we've taken is to use the noun
population which is this amazing
resource in maize natural variation
resource generated by a major Goodman
and made famous by adviser and many
other people here so this is a diversity
population with diverse 25 diverse
founder lines so we want to find natural
variation in our trade of interest which
is faced iation so we take one of our
mutants like Faye - and we cross it -
all of the diversity parents and then
make F twos and score the phenotypes so
we're looking for modified as genetic
modifiers and it's a lot of work but
it's kind of fun to just walk through
the field and get up and in ten thousand
years it's one of my favourite
activities but not for everybody but
anyway when we did this we found that
one of these lines which is NC 350
strongly enhanced the Fae - phenotype
right so NC 350 by itself is not face
eiated right these are just natural for
i inbred varieties but when we cross NC
350 with say - and make an F - we go
from a pretty strong face iation
phenotype looks like this so that
meristem is really flattened and that
ear is flattened and then we get
something like
this which is just completely crazy just
really faced it kind of looks like a
brain and I get my neuro your biologist
colleagues interested in this till I
realized yeah so it's so it's really
strongly an end so we want to know you
know there's some locus in NC 350 that's
doing this it's in in wild-type NC 350
it's not doing anything to the meristem
but when we put it in an immutable on
which we think sensitize is that the
plan then we see this really strong
enhancement
so we mapped this in actually this was
originally really difficult to map
because there's a lot of things
segregating here and it's probably not
just one major locus but we'd so we do
several back crosses and make an f2 and
we found a major locus on chromosome
five that the maps to this trait and we
map this and right in the middle is one
of our favorite genes they have a really
talked about you at TD 1 which is amazed
cavada one about a one receptor if FA 2
is clever tattoo and TD one is Claddagh
one so it makes perfect sense a little
bit disappointing is nothing new but I
think it's interesting that within this
line we found in this natural variation
in T V 1 which can enhance this trade
and we've shown we've confirmed this by
mutants and also I said I don't have it
here in the slide but there is a
difference in expression in TD 1 in NC
350 compared to be 73 which was our
starting line so it's it's interesting
and I think this is a an extra resource
we can hopefully use to uncover new
alpha in the future new loci also that
control these traits
okay so last part of the talk I want to
just come back to this idea again about
increasing yield or at least increasing
kernel number so again the idea is these
mutants make massive disorganized
meristems the yield is very low but if
we can control this gene I a weak allele
we could make a little bit bigger sense
and more rows ok so originally we did
this together with a tilling facility in
May
set up by cliff while Purdue and
whee-hee-hee screen for us in EMS
populations for alleles of Fae - that
had on mute ations generated by EMS just
by by sequencing we had four of these
and they're predicted to give single
amino acid changes presumably weak
alleles and for one of these at least
two two of them but one was more
dramatic we actually found that indeed
in these mutants these weak alleles of
Fae - we do get an increase in Colonel
rose from an average of about 16 to
Navarrete about 20 which is quite
dramatic a lot more kernels per ear and
everybody was excited about this I
wasn't really excited about this I was
really excited about this which is when
we look at these in the scanning
eeehm we see that indeed these weak
alleles if they to the meristems do
indeed get a bit bigger but they're
still organized still this nice dome
shape they're not satiated splittings
right so I was really happy about this
okay so we're making more kernels do we
make more yield well the answer is no
right so as I was discussing we Bob this
morning you know plants are pretty smart
you know you try and trick it into
making more rows of seats and they say
well you know I'm just gonna make the
seeds smaller so that that's what the
plant did so there was no increase in
yield in this background which is not
you know what farmers grow this is w22
so it's not even in a hybrid which is
what we normally grow but you know we've
been giving these lines out Greta's here
and there and actually a former postdoc
in my lab is now a maize breeder in
vietnam and he put this into one it into
their breeding lines that they actually
grow the farmers grow and they again saw
an increase in kernel row number and in
their yield trials is his real breeders
yield trials this is not our crappy
field in in Long Island they saw up to a
20% increase in yield so that's pretty
encouraging it needs to be reproduced
but I think in some backgrounds this may
really have an effect we did this with
another gene that we were done called
Fay 3 I haven't really talked about this
today
in this example we had weak alleles see
they're still mildly face eiated but not
nothing like the null mutant again
there's a EMS weak alleles in this case
even in our you know old inbreds and
hybrids
it's just b7 3w 22 we see a pretty
significant increase in yield again this
is not elite varieties of course but
encouraging that we may do this so maybe
these marathon pathways are interacting
somehow in pathways a controlled sync
strength right so the plant only has a
limited amount of resources but what it
does without resources I think is a
mystery how that's did how that's
decided so there may be some interaction
okay so we want to do this large-scale
and I think with the EMS alleles we were
really lucky to get alleles that had the
desired effect so we want to make a more
generalizable approach to make weak
alleles in plants right and targeting
the protein sequence is a little risky
because you might you know you could not
have the whole protein you don't really
know what you're gonna get and EMS is
kind of messy and slow and so now of
course we have CRISPR which is just
amazing new tool so to make weak alleles
we don't want to tug in the coding
sequence but maybe we thought maybe we
can target the promoters so again this
is with our with our clean mutants in
maze what we do is we take the predicted
promoter region and we don't care about
promoter elements everybody asks like
how did you predict which promoter
element is important blah blah blah I
don't care I just want to get a
phenotype right so we just we take the
upstream once 2 KB of promoter and just
tile it with 8 or 9 guide RNAs then we
transform this into maze and what we get
out is plants that have all sorts of
different phenotype genotype so so
basically we have small in Dells which
is very common with CRISPR but if you do
CRISPR with multiple guide RNAs you also
often get large deletions so we get
different promoted deletions so this is
like in vivo promoter botchey I mean
when I was a graduate student everybody
was doing promoter botchey
it was I thought it was really boring
but
quite excited about this because it's in
vivo in the native genomic context and I
wish I had a lot of results from this
you may have seen a paper published a
few months ago from Zack Lippmann so
we're doing this together with Lippmann
laughs using a tomato and tomato as much
faster than maize and they already have
amazing allelic variation in tomato the
only thing I can show in maize which is
not very satisfying is that we do have
some weak phenotypes and weak face
iation
but no no yield idea but that's coming
next so I think it can work there's no
reason it shouldn't work I think it's
pretty exciting so where are we so I
think I've hopefully convinced you or
confused you that the Claddagh Network
is very confusing and complex you know
and CRISPR is just beginning so it's
gonna get a lot worse you know we used
to be in this great situation where we
had okhla vada three binds cavada one
that regulates which one is feedback but
we now know that there are many more
receptors the function in meristem
control and then always downstream
signaling components and there are a lot
more that paper I just reviewed has four
more over here that will be coming out
soon so yeah there's a lot more stuff
coming so it is very confusing but in a
way that's biology and it's satisfying I
mean it's interesting to think about why
it's so complicated
we could discuss that later but yeah it
is complicated but we're making headway
and then there's the please so clavata
three is this as I said is is Cle it's a
peptide it's a member of a big gene
family they're actually 49 in maize and
I didn't dare ask my postdoc to knock
out all of them but he's actually done
about 20 of them already so this is a
amazing not all in the same plant right
so they ought because together but the
amazing power of CRISPR you know we we
now gently knocking out four genes at
once and we could go tomorrow I'm sure
so it's really things are going to
change very quickly so it so we're
focusing on only about 30 so I decided
to be more modest in
my expectations but the ones are the
most highly expressing inflorescence
ofcourse and I'm sure there'll be lots
of interesting phenotypes coming out of
this probably more than we can ever ever
study but but I think it's it's very
powerful now to think about you know
know looking at single genes because we
know that redundancy is very prevalent
in plants and so we need to think about
knocking out whole gene families to find
the phenotypes okay and then so how
complicated is it very and then
something I think about a lot also is to
what extent is yield to crop yields
limits by sync and when I talk about
this a lot of people say well yield is
sauce limited right the plant only makes
a certain amount of force in fade and
all that goes to the ear and then you
can't make more by making the ear bigger
because you only have a certain amount
of resources but I don't know if that's
true and in some of our works yes it may
not be true right I mean the resources
may be some of the resources are kept in
the roots or or you know kept in the
leaves and weird funneling more of that
into the ear and whether that's good
enough for sustainability I don't know
but it's interesting to think about
whether this can be used to enhance
yield maybe this has already been
optimized in Kahn belt maze because
freed has been breeding maize for you
know almost 100 years but probably not
in all environments as I showed you with
the lines from Vietnam and certainly
there's a lot of interest now in
developing new crops right often often
crops improving them and they think
these pathways could be very useful in
improving yield in in crops that are not
commonly row crops now okay so yeah I
just want to acknowledge people who did
this these are in greener that people
involve in cavada related projects the
other people doing different things a
lot of the work Justin by a very
talented postdoc young Lu just got a job
back in Korea and also Peter bomb it is
back in Germany and then we have a great
group of collaborators and funding
agencies and etc okay and thanks very
much
[Applause]
yeah the translate well that depends on
how these things do at high density
which we have not measured yet so that's
but they with its it's ongoing but yeah
signatures of selection yeah I mean they
yeah I didn't go into this but a lot of
these genes come up in QTL scans or in G
wasps studies so yeah so there is um
there's variation that's associated with
yield traits all-weather selected yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah it's an
interesting question so these genes did
not come out in the doble screen right
so doubly crossed ancient maize and
teosinte and found major cutie ELLs five
major QTL so these genes are not in
those there is one interesting gene in
there actually fee the maize leafy
homologue which he showed may be also
involved in controlling row numbers yeah
so I think of these genes is not in the
image original domestication events the
more in improvement events the more
recent so they they well they do not
come up in the early data said they td1
actually came out of work the paper
published last year I think in Current
Biology that Jeff Ross Navarro is on
where they sequence ancient leis from
these five thousand year old cobs and
they found that td1 was already in the
selection notes yeah I think it's that
but we haven't looked to deeply
understand proxy for meristem size any
examples where you see essentially more
colonel ropes but the meristem looks
yeah I dad yeah so we actually it
happens and of see Colonel size can vary
so you can get more rows by having
smaller criminals we originally we
looked at all the num founder lines and
tried to correlate Colonel row number
with wearisome size and I think meristem
size variation explained about sixty
percent of the difference in final run
of it so it's not it's not all of it
essential part of it so the Association
it's not you're right right yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the question is about this
sort of branching receptor pathway and
whether the receptor interacts directly
with G officer so we published that
paper in 2013 that you know the receptor
interacts with G alpha and then you know
he went off and got his job and you know
he left a lab and then another post I
joined and could not repeat it cuz I was
really would never throw a while but
eventually come the conditions right in
it he repeated it so it is true but we
detect the interaction by colloid P but
not by fret or B or C so we think
there's a another protein that breaches
that interaction and we think that is a
receptor that we haven't yeah we haven't
been able to purify it yet we have a
kind of database um so I think maze is
somehow more sensitized so I think we
find well so we found a lot of things in
a rabid OPS's that's right a maze that
have not been found in robots it's like
faithful G alpha
they three then when we've gone back and
looked more carefully in Arabidopsis we
found the phenotypes either by making
double mutant or yes I we haven't seen
anything that's really obvious and I'm
kind of happy about this you know I I
have this sort of friendly back and
forth with Elliot Meyerowitz that cos
you know he he's a bit he's not he has a
bit of an ego I'd say so so I he'll just
if we find something in maze that hasn't
been found in Arabidopsis he'll just say
oh well you just show that things are
weird inmates but but I don't think it
is I think they're the same this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu